good evening and welcome to this
strategy and resources committee
on thursday the 11th of november my name
is councillor richard siddall and i am
the chairman of the committee before we
commence the business of the meeting
there are a few housekeeping issues to
run through
members the setup for this meeting is
designed to mitigate for covid and
therefore i'd ask everyone present to
work to the protocols agreed by the
council in the interest of everyone's
safety
we're streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent to being
recorded members and officers during its
item please put your hand up to indicate
if you wish to speak i will then invite
you at the appropriate time
please reference a page number or
paragraph uh refer referring to the
independence regarding the different
kind of
skipped uh please
refer to a paragraph
referring to the agenda papers not to
the floor uh keeping your contributions
clear and concise as possible and ensure
your microphones remain off when not
speaking can i draw your attentions to
the notice of agenda papers regarding
the levels and advise that the fire exit
is behind me
as some of you may know there's been
some changes in leadership of the
council due to these changes i've been
resigning by chairman of strategy
resources
i've really enjoyed my time as chairman
of strategy resources and i hope that
whoever takes over will enjoy as much as
i have
my final note is i would like to
recognize that and thank the work and
the contribution of councillor wendy
stam and councillor stephen nunn who've
led the council in the past year or year
or so
they've worked really hard and
constructively and made a huge
difference to the council
and i think we should all commend them
for that they took over a very difficult
time for this council during the cavity
period and they've handled that
extremely well and i personally would
like to thank them for the work that
they've done for this council and for
the residents of malden district
so move to item two apologies for
absence
uh tara may have apologies for us thank
you chairman apologies been received
from council boys and councillor thank
you okay um in terms of item two i'd
also like to record that we have a
member in attendance and the member in
attendance is councillor chrissy morris
could that be noted please tara
thank you very much
uh
me too item number three the minutes of
the 15th the 16th of september 2021
found on pages 5-72 are approved as a
true and accurate record by some say do
i have a secondar
counselor's way
uh if any member wishes to raise any
matters of accuracy they need to
indicate that they wish to and i would
like to raise a matter of accuracy
uh on this i would like to raise a max
maturity at the september meeting i made
an announcement regarding behaviour at
the july meeting
have i listened to the recording i
realized i may have misheard how i
referred was i was referred to
and i would like these comments to be
retracted and the particular comments i
would like retracted from the minutes
are
the final sentence which is the chairman
expressed concern regarding behaviour at
the last meeting this committee but he
was not showing the respect as the
chairman and hopeless did not happen
again so tara could that please return
attracted from the militants
i would also like to say how sorry i am
that councilor white who as a result of
this has been the victim of abuse
and i hope that this does not continue
as i said at the last meeting we all
have to work ethically
respect diversity equality and show
respect and we should all be working
towards that and my thoughts go to
councillor white
so can we agree those minutes via ascent
members
thank you
so now move to your item number four
disclosure of interest
disclose the existence and nature of any
disposable impunity interest
it was uh on the top on the team's
street
it was on the teams in one of the
offices
that's awesome again on that
to displace
the existence of any disclosable
peculiar interest other peculiar
interests or non-pecuniary interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda that have regard to paragraph six
to eight includes the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they are required to disclose any such
interest as soon as they become aware
should denise arrive throughout the
meeting members are there any matters of
interest
uh councillor durham
yeah um thank you chairman it's a
non-cunary interest as a member of essex
county council for any matter that comes
up relating to that authority thank you
thank you councillor darren councillor
stan um yes the same um chairman a
member of essex county council
non-procuring if anything comes up in
relation to it and i realize that then
i'll state it
chairman thank you thank you council
staff
so now we move to item number five which
is public partition
i can't talk tonight that's my
public participation even
um i can advise that we have not
received any submissions from members of
the public
so now move on to item number six which
is budget should control april to
september 2021 found on pages
73-88 and this is going to be presented
by mr leslie the director of resources
mr leslie
thank you chair
table 1 at paragraph 4.1 of the report
shows the forecast split between
staffing
and non-staffing expenditure and income
there is a total of six hundred thousand
pound service expenditure variance
forecast due to the shortfall of income
relating largely to the ongoing covered
pandemic
tables three and four of the report
shows what areas make up the majority of
the non-staffing expenditure and income
respectively so that these areas can be
better understood
the main driver for the overspend
relates to the management fee income for
black water leisure centre of 629
thousand pounds
however since repairing the report the
performance of the center has been
better than forecasts and it is expected
to be a better year end position
the working group will meet on the 2nd
december
to receive an update of the latest
forecasts on performance
town centre parking has also not
returned to pre-pandemic levels and
overall parking is expected to be a
hundred thousand pounds down against the
budget
a contingency of 371 000 was put in the
budget for covered pressures and once
this
grants from governments income
compensation scheme
and the improvement in investment
returns are factored in the budget
variance is reduced to 112 000 pounds
overall this would reduce the general
fund balance from 5.8 million to just
over 5.6 million which is above the
recommended minimum level of 2.6 million
thank you mr leslie
so the recommendations are set out on
the report that the committee notes the
firecasted 20 21 22 financial position
at the midpoint of the financial year do
i have a second to please
uh councillor durham
uh i'd now like to invite members to uh
speak or ask any questions on the report
counselor channel
why is it these things always disappear
when you're looking for them
but i'm sure you will call what it is
because it is an item and it's there
sorry i'll take that off while i'm
speaking it is the waste and cycling uh
waste and recycling not cycling but i
can't speak
must be catching
um and about the figure hundred and
eighty one thousand the extra vehicle
um now i recognize we've had problems
but can you just explain a bit about the
extra vehicle because
um
there was driver shortages and that
seemed to be an issue for the authority
or for the the company they do seem to
have a lot of vehicles so just tell me
how that cost has been aggregated if you
like
and then what are the effects on our
recycling targets and i'm bearing in
mind what we're doing also for other
things like green waste and extending
but just interested in that figure 181
000 is that a contract
amendment or whatever you would call it
um
slide
yeah thank you
uh so 185 thousand there's more detail
um
provided at uh i think it's appendix uh
a
of the report that gives a bit more of a
breakdown in terms of the actual areas
where we've had um pressures
from but in terms of the additional
vehicle
we needed to put on extra vehicles due
to the increase in waste that's been
produced since the covered pandemic
so during the covered pandemic we've had
about a 20 increase in uh recycling so
the vehicle relates to recycling so
we've seen a huge increase uh in that i
think largely because people are at home
more they're not going out the waste is
pretty induced in the house rather than
out and about so we've seen that
latest figures show that the recycling
rate um or the increase in recycling is
still 15
above pre-pandemic levels so without
additional vehicles to actually go out
and collect um the recycling we couldn't
be able to cope with the additional
waste it's been created on the positive
side there has been an increase in
demand uh the price we're able to get
for our recycling which has
increased uh the expected level of
income for for that element and i think
that will factor in uh more towards the
uh out turn the year-end report as we go
thank you so was it contract variation
that's the word i was looking for the
extra vehicle how was that that's
covered so that was done through the
proper route yeah but that's that's part
of the contract variation that comes in
where we've agreed to vary that and pay
that for the time thank you chairman
okay councillor white
uh thank you um chair um
yeah my query really um was on the extra
vehicle funnily enough um because i've
got a resident in my ward i have raised
this with the waste officers um who has
their or did have their green waist
collected along with their refuse
and
her husband died so she didn't pay for a
year which i fully accept and
we were trying to get it somehow
reinstated
but i hadn't had she heard back and i
wasn't aware that we paid for a new
vehicle and i wonder if we have the
extra capacity whether we can reinstate
um this ladies greenways collection as
it goes with the refuse and because she
is very elderly as i have raised it
there was supposed to be a meeting but i
don't actually know what the outcome was
and i wondered if i could be involved in
any meetings with suez to perhaps see if
we could facilitate it as we now have an
extra vehicle that we're paying for
it's
mrs green to you or mr holmes do you
know whether there's still
availability in terms of the
garden waste recycling
uh
thank you chairmason not going off yes
thank you chairman um yes there is an
extra vehicle but that might not
necessarily help with the green waste
round but what i will do is outside of
this meeting i'm arranged to contact you
and i can speak to the officer and we
can have a conversation
i might just come back it doesn't get
collected with the green waste it gets
collected with the normal refuse vehicle
because it's one of the non-standard
addresses
okay thank you i will i'll follow that
another meeting with you on that
mr james
uh councillor dora
yeah thank you chairman it's um
i just really wanted to raise something
um
not particularly in relation to the
figures we got in front of us but um and
something that i should probably propose
as a growth item um i
had cause to
uh be at the malden cemetery um
yesterday in actual fact and was really
struck by the professionalism of the
staff there
um and i had quite a long i have
actually contacted mr holmes to
congratulate them but the comment very
much came that
unfortunately we're not able to maintain
the cemeteries as they would like on
account of the shortage of staff so
looking at the cemeteries a it's
something that almost every resident or
a large number of residents have access
to or or have caused to use eventually
bill will one day um
it generates hundred and forty odd
thousand pounds worth of revenue could
be considerably more so as i said it
will probably be
considered as a growth item for next
year but
the other reason for mentioning it is i
wanted to put on record
how brilliant our staff
have been in a difficult time
thank you councillor
uh mr holmes
thank you chairman uh yes i'm happy to
have that conversation around the growth
items for the cemetery service i know mr
norman who's on the call this evening
he's actually doing a review at this
moment in terms of the staffing of the
parks team um i have said that um we
obviously got the opportunity to present
to members a case for growth so we will
make sure if that's to happen for this
part of this year year's cycle and we're
looking at doing work on the buildings
there to again increase
the services that can be helped yes
there's a number of um activities around
the cemetery some of them which as you
say adaptations to buildings and
improvements some are about the
maintenance itself which may need some
additional resources so we will look at
that as a growth item yeah kevin if i
might just you might just come back i
mean we all know there's a there's a
plenty a pending planning application
for a crematorium in our district which
is even going to be make things even
more important that our facilities match
what will be there because obviously it
will be brand new and um
and will take a lot of business thank
you that's council don any other items
okay
so therefore members can we agree that
by our ascent
thank you very much
excuse me
so we moved to agenda item seven which
is supplementary estimates environments
procurement accepts exceptions and use
of reserves from the first of september
2021 to the 31st october
2021 pages 89-92
mr leslie
this time we have two environments for
the committee to note at paragraph
3.2.1 where legal budgets were moved
under legal services to
better reflect budget ownership
there are two supplementary estimates to
note at paragraph
3.3.1 totaling 17 and a half thousand
pounds these relate to urgent repairs
that were required
and there are seven procurement
exemptions at paragraph
3.4.1
to ensure procurement rules were
complied with
thank you mr leslie
so the
recommendations that are set out and the
report are as follows a little one that
the environments are
detailed in paragraph 3.2.1 other this
report be noted little two that
supplementary estimates as detailed in
paragraph at
3.3.1 how this report be noted and
little three that the procurement
exemptions as detailed in paragraph
3.4.1
united do i have a second
counselor durham thank you
members do you have any questions at all
uh counselor seancy
thank you chairman
i would just like to ask
mr leslie if i'm a chairman
about the first aid cover on the prom
it's on page 91 i'd just like to know
what that consists of please um in
relation to um
when
some people at the museum the other day
and someone took ill and
and people weren't sure i i wasn't there
myself but people weren't for um
what to do or what was going on so i
would like to know that please mr leslie
thank you so this relates to ensure with
every appropriate first aiders um around
the area so obviously we opened up our
splash park and events and this is just
to ensure that there was sufficient
first aid cover available um for our
facilities around that so it's mainly
relating to the express parking events
and mr holmes
and that is for a period of time in the
busiest part of the summer so we don't
provide um first day cover throughout
the year on the part but the peak
seasons we do we have additional
resources
i see and may i have a quick
supplementary gemma thank you um so
either mr leslie or mr holmes um
could other people
go to use the first aid
um sort of if they're not using the
splash park
that's chairman yes it's first day for
the park itself they have to be based
around that area but they are available
for for anybody on the planet
thank you so much thank you chairman
council shawnee council channel
thank you chairman um i'd like to go to
page 91 and it's bottom of the table
item seven
eleven thousand pounds i know this is an
exemption for procurement rules but
gypsy and travel accommodation
assessment update
and it says additional work by existing
contractor which you undertaken by a
different contractor would result in
technical inconsistencies in the final
report what exactly does that mean
chairman maybe i'm being rather
thick here but i had a little difficulty
really trying to reconcile what that
actually meant yeah happy to expand
um it relates to ldp work local
development plan work where we needed to
take on
a
contractor to carry out some assessment
this is a contractor that
used past assessment and also provided a
lot of the assessment for the whole of
essex um so they have that background
knowledge and consistency
and if we used another contractor
there's concerns actually uh that they
would have to undertake some of the work
that's already been done by that
contractor and perhaps will provide the
consistencies um around the uh the wider
essex area um as well so it's a cost and
efficiency jeremy just to comment if i
may
had perhaps the word ldp or a bit of
explanation that's not a criticism but
then i wouldn't have had my mind sort of
thinking a bit laterally if you like
thank you it's quite a convoluted
sentence as well chad
uh councillor white
thank you
chair um
just to say that um councillor chana um
uh raised the question i was going to
raise all part of it and what i wanted
to know was why is it so expensive
because we only have a handful of sites
in the whole district so i'm a bit
surprised as to how it's cost 11 000
pounds just to do an update um well we
really don't have very many and i would
imagine you could do them in a day
so i just wondered how that that cost
was made up um but it doesn't really
seem
you know very logical
um thank you chairman i i don't have the
detail to hand to answer that question
but happy to to look further into the
detail behind the
what what it entailed in the in the
assessment
um and provide that for you
there is i ask is because we pay the
however much it is a year into the
travelers gypsy and travelers
payment scheme with its current council
currently what it's called
um and they they were aware of all the
gypsy and traveler sites within the
district and that's why i'm surprised
because i think there's only is it four
sites we've got i can't remember like i
think license has only got two is it
there's this to do with the pen central
and review of the in the ldp that rather
than what we have at the moment
so it's about what we might need in the
future
yes so so the what we're paying for what
we do at the moment is what we've got
this is about saying in terms of the lgp
and in terms of our assessment what
might be the future requirements for the
in the ldp
grief 11 000 for that wow that seems um
but maybe i'm wrong maybe there's more
work than it seems but i thought we had
a surplus before
okay thank you councillor white
so
uh can we agree oh sorry counselor
durham i wasn't sure whether you've been
scratching my head earlier no
i think i was probably doing both and
actually both counselor channel and and
councillor white have sort of um asked
the same question i was going to
question that about gypsy and traveler
because um
we don't have any sites actually that
belong to the district council um the
sites are all owned by essex county
council i mean that is wood wood corner
um and to just to help out councillor
white she's referring to et2 which is
the essex county travellers unit which
is a completely different beast
altogether act 2
isn't involved with any of the private
or illegal sites
at all eq2 simply provides assistance
for authorities
in cases of illegal encampments on
uh publicly owned land and it also works
with
from a welfare point of view with the
settled travelers on the essex county
council sites so that's what we pay the
poultry sum of eight thousand pounds um
a year for but i i would say that i
think eleven thousand pounds for a
survey that does sound like quite a lot
to me but there you go thank you yeah if
uh the strategy team can come back with
more detail on those figures
okay thank you mr son thank you
councillor darren
uh so can we agree those recommendations
by ascent members
thank you very much
so we now move on to agenda item eight
uh 20 21 22 half yearly treasury
management update on pages 93 202
again mr leslie
so the report provides a media update on
the council's treasury management
activities
table 1 at paragraph 3.4.2
shows the type of institutions the
council holds investments with
at the mid-year position which are banks
building societies money market funds
and the uk government as well as other
local authorities
the council also holds five million
pounds of long-term investments in a
property fund and a diversified income
fund
section 3.5 details the returns that the
council has received
with long-term investments performing
strongly
and investment income is expected to be
sixty thousand pounds higher than
budgeted um this year
table two uh paragraph three point six
point one details the occasions the
council's current account has exceeded
two million pounds as required by the
treasury management strategy
officers are currently working with our
treasury advisors to bring forward a
revised strategy for next year to
increase that limit in recognition that
the current account handles daily cash
flows and is not a distinct investment
like the other balances
appendix 2 of the report shows
performance against the prudential
indicators that have been set in the
strategy
this includes the fact that there was no
borrowing required
average investment credit score was
within target
and sufficient cash was available
so the recommendations are set out in
the report that the members review
the treasury management report for
compliance purposes do i have a second
to please counsel this way thank you
members uh any comments or questions
okay can we agree those via sent members
thank you very much
so we move to agenda item nine which is
22 23 this charges policy found on pages
100 to 108
members please note that in the report
it says that the years are 21 22
but this is for next year not this year
uh mr leslie
thank you so that's quite right the
policy is for 2223
and paragraph 3.3 highlights where there
are changes proposed from the current
policy
uh the majority of these changes uh
relate to ensuring charges take into
account both cost of recovery as well as
the market rate uh the policy has also
been discussed at the finance working
group
the detailed charges will be presented
to a future meeting of this committee
mr leslie
so the recommendations are set out in
the report as follows to the council
that the 22 23 fears and charges
policies at appendix a b approved do i
have a second
councillor swain thank you very much
members any questions on anything uh
councillor white
uh thank you chair um i just wanted to
sort of ask what the commercial services
box office was whether we're doing a
service to do box office collections for
events from other companies that was a
bit surprised by that one or is it where
we're handling fees for like the let's
and things on the website
that's leslie or mr butcher
yeah it's the um
yeah thank you it's where we uh act as a
box office a ticket uh facilitator um
for these sort of events that's a
charging policy it's whether we can
obviously have the capacity to do that
and i think i think that's one of the
questions obviously with the teams and
sheen what sort of service can we
provide for the events that take place
over there as well the packages that we
potentially could provide
does it make a profit um when we're
doing this
yeah i think that's one of the things
you have to look at with individual
events take place it's actually the cost
to us and uh
is it producing the return um to us i
think that's a very valid question and
it needs to be taken on a sort of event
by event basis and that's the sort of
thing we're looking at
at the moment as well to make sure the
charges are fit for purpose and are
correct
are you happy that councilwoman
well not really because we shouldn't be
taking on anything if we don't can't be
guaranteed that it's going to make a
profit that that's my main concern is
we're supposed to be making it a
commercial entity and and if we don't
know if we're making a profit from doing
something stop doing it if you can't be
certain it makes a profit then then
don't
and that's i think part of the review is
this is exactly the reason
uh councillor channel
thank you chairman well obviously i've
got all the figures here and i
appreciate that and as to why because
we're really greeting the principles of
the policy um however chairman can i two
uh two questions really um obviously i'm
taking it this has been through the
finance working group so what is before
members tonight in terms of the policy
principles is there anything
strategically greatly different from
what that working group may have
considered eg we you know what changes
were officers recommending a networking
group actually altered or whatever plus
of course i appreciate there's lots of
things here where the market rates being
achieved or based on that or that's the
change in policy recommended
what about
inflation rate and issues like that
because when you look at the predictions
going forward was that taken forward in
the equation of some of these policy
considerations because obviously you
know inflation is a real issue and we
want to ensure
um you know i'm not trying to
um you know do the taxpayer anything but
obviously we can't necessarily afford if
inflation rates aren't lots of these
things may have
um costs um applicable to the council we
need to ensure we're covering our bases
really
leslie
thank you so yeah spreading through the
the working group um i don't believe
there's anything that's particularly
material change but i happy obviously
for those members of the working group
to to say um otherwise in terms of the
um
excuse me
in terms of the other um
questions
yes brilliant thank you yeah inflation
sorry um yeah what we have done uh
previously is actually uh take the
inflation figure to um
the next report which includes the
detailed fees and charges um so last
year we used this uh the figure came
there um so that was a plan to take the
same figure um this time but obviously
it has increased the cpi and that will
be of course reflected in the in the
next report
thank you very much thank you council
channel uh
yeah thank you i was just going to move
back onto the the box office
i think you know i know we're not
discussing the rates now
but if we move much above 10 the the
the venue organizers won't use us
because they'll use eventbrite who
charge 10
so you know provided we're making a
profit on that we do something we don't
want to lose because
it's money for all rape in actual fact
so to use a phrase it's finding that
balance i think that's the crucial thing
in terms of these things ensuring that
we have a balanced approach and and then
we don't do anything that then
you know pushes it out of the
marketplace
so members uh can we uh agree those by
ascent
thank you very much
so we now move on to
gender item 10 which is the climate
action strategy
found on pages 109 to 138
mr dodson to present the report
thank you chairman
on the 4th of february of this year the
council declared a climate emergency and
stated it that it was the first step
towards a cleaner and more sustainable
council
benefiting both residents and future
generations
from march until now
the development of a climate action
strategy has taken place
this work has been informed by officers
from across the council and by members
of the climate action strategy working
group
the strategy sets out the local and
national picture and the pivotal role of
the council in taking action at a local
level
under the title of our home our future
the strategy sets out five climate
action pledges
and a set of aspirations for the council
and the district to focus on
the pledges are
to kick the car habit
create less waste
show nature we care
be an authority that leads by example
and have a strong policy commitment to
climate action
strategy also talks about the the
current strategies and policies in place
that already support climate action
and further talks about our partners and
the engagement we wish to carry out with
our communities
young people
and local businesses
in particular giving young people a lead
voice
we already have interest from residents
young people schools community groups
and local businesses in supporting
climate action by becoming our climate
action friends
to take this strategy forward into
delivery
an annual action plan will be produced
and updated each year
along with launching
our home our future engagement campaign
the work will be led by a climate action
officer who's yet to be recruited
in conclusion
climate action continues to be a
priority topic for government
the council is somewhat behind the curve
in comparison to some other local
authorities and would benefit from
having this climate action strategy to
ensure it actively reduces impact and
harm to the environment and looks to
build resilience for the future
thank you chairman thank you mr dudson
so the recommendations has set out on
the report is little one
that the progress that has been made in
developing the climate action strategy
through the work of the climate action
member working group united and its
recommendation for approval acknowledged
and then to the council little two that
the climate action strategy be approved
and endorsed do i have a second to
please cancel a stamp thank you
members counselor stamp
thank you chairman
um i think it's fabulous i think this
council has wanted to do something like
this for quite some time
and i think the officers have worked
extremely hard to produce this a lot of
background work and information has been
carried out i'd like to take the
opportunity to single out one particular
officer which is georgina button
she has worked tremendously hard with
the support of mr dodson and the the
rest of the team but she has really
pulled out all the stops chairman um i
think it's uh a subject um that is
obviously critical to everybody
uh for the younger generation as well as
um our generations german and and i
really welcome that this council is
engaging with everybody um who has has
to be engaged with um my postbugs been
full i think it was me who really
promoted this to come when i was leader
to be come to fruition and like
councillor durham i remember him turning
around and saying it should have been in
a long time ago and really putting the
pressure on but i would personally like
to thank everybody and the members as
well who has actually helped to push
this forward and i think it's important
that we have the officer who's going to
be employed to take this forward we
can't afford to take our foot off the
gas oh i think that's a bit of a
power isn't it or something but you know
what i mean we can't afford to take our
foot off and we have to make sure and if
anybody members of the public and
officers
and members have any suggestions um to
actually improve it then please can we
all get on and get to get it done and
stick together um so i'd like to thank
george unibutter button especially we've
all got a problem with our team
thank you chairman thank you councillor
stan
excellent words counselor dora
thank you chairman
i think we pretty much all now recognize
that climate change is going to be one
of the biggest issues facing
humanity us and our children our
children's children
um
but strategies and words are great
is action that we need and i'm afraid
we're seeing precious little action
with no charging electric charging
points in our car parks we have to my
knowledge no sailor on our roofs
we are way way behind authorities like
braintree for example and indeed essex
that are i mean braintree are streets
ahead of us um so i would sincerely hope
if we are
employing an officer and i totally
support that
that we don't try and reinvent the wheel
there is an awful lot of previous
experience and
expertise out there that we should be
dialing into we're way behind the curve
and we should use be using other people
because not everybody's got everything
right and we shouldn't be making the
same mistakes that they've made and the
only way to avoid doing that is to speak
to people but it's absolutely it's
action we need we were one of the first
people in the area to put electric
charging points in the in our car park
this car parked here
and i remember looking out the window
many a time to see you know i was
waiting for the first car that appeared
and it was a long long time and i saw
the other day both were being used
but without wishing to
quote lady thundberg blah blah blah is
all very well we actually need to
not talk about it but actually do some
things
thank you councillor durham
i'll come to you in a minute
mr councillor jarvis uh yeah the the
thing is yeah about this is is we do
have a lot of strategy being developed
and we don't have the resources to
implement them and that's that's been
one of the finalist issues over the last
year or so is ensuring that we've got
the resources and we're trying to change
that i know for a fact that council
stamp has been working with our
authorities and learning from other
authorities to bring that expertise and
to and to ensure that we are
using the lessons learned from other
organizations and council stampers were
really hard in terms of doing that
so yeah we we understand all that
counsellor and and you know we're
hopefully going to make sure that it
happens to the right counselor jarvis
thank you very much chairman um
i know the comments that other
councillors have made and would agree
entirely that this is a very important
uh project uh not just now but obviously
over the next few decades uh my question
though is just that when it comes as a
strategy to council i think would be
quite important to have some sort of
cost cost information in terms of you
know see recruitment in terms of annual
spend or in fact any income streams and
benefits so i think obviously uh
whilst it's obviously a very good thing
to be doing it's very important to
understand what we're going to be
committing to it i'm very well aware as
i'm sure all counselors are of the
rather fragile uh sort of medium term
finances this council may face
so it's right that we even though this
is a very laudable project we should put
it into context to know how much how
much of a budget we're going to be
spending on it and how how much that
impacts our medium-term finances thank
you chad
uh and you know
cancel something to come back to what
council josh just said yeah if that's
right
any other member wanting to speak yeah
so yeah
okay so um
i've i've got your counsellor
thank you we will use this this strategy
to attract external funding it gives us
a platform to do that and we're already
in in discussions um with some funders
around how we do that and how we attract
funding for the the aspirations that are
within it
we don't have all of the budget
available to deliver the aspirations
within this
strategy
but
we need to develop them we need to make
sure that we're we are attracting them
and it needs to be aspirational because
whilst we don't have that funding now
unless we put these aspirations in and
use it as a basis to attract those funds
then we won't be able to address the
issues there may be some match funding
requirements on the council in doing
that but we will work very closely with
partners as well across the the county
and wider if if need be to put in joint
bids because this requires action by
everybody
yeah just as a supplementary to that
chairman i think that's i understand
that in terms of the bigger picture i
think in terms of asking the council to
commit to something it would be a good
idea to have a sort of financial plan
um that at least says well how much are
we going to commit of the council money
before perhaps you know if it doesn't
all work out how much are we going to
commit to this uh of our money so to
speak so i think those sort of numbers
do need to be put together when when
council is asked to agree a strategy i
fully understand the aspirational aspect
and we all hope that comes good but i
always think it's a good idea as a
contingency to know how much is we're on
the hook for if the the money doesn't
come in thank you are those figures
available mr dodson
those will be developed through through
the action plan this is the overall
strategy the action plan will be fully
costed and deliverable and we'll plan
that every year to ensure their
deliverable activity within that thank
you and that's why we need the resources
to do the work yeah so we're right catch
22. uh i'll come to a minute when uh
uh cancer china
um
thank you very much chairman chairman i
think the officer that's been referred
to is a growth bid if i remember
correctly from the report so obviously
that's got to be agreed
but i'm interested in the engagement
activities um
and obviously getting the community
engaged because from what i've read and
and seen this is largely going to rely
heavily on community engagement and
young people having an opportunity to be
involved because let's face it young
people are our future and they're very
well educated on this issue and and will
be a great asset to the way forward i'd
be very interested to actually see the
the constituent makeup of the community
engagement group i think it can be a
changing feast from conversation i had
with
georgina because i've got some people
i've recently thought of and i said is
there a timeline on this and i think we
can get people engaged so that's the
point i would make and also
counselor durham touched on it we can't
do it ourselves
alone this is about working in
partnership working with essex county
council a host of other bodies
those with knowledge etc and obviously
partners that might want to engage with
us in the community i was very
disappointed i couldn't attend the last
workshop i think it was the last one
where this actually was considered them
by the working group because i sit on it
that was due to family illness but i
just like to iterate the amount of hard
work that's gone in an echo
council of stamps
comments regarding georgina button i
think to pull this amount of work
bearing in mind everything else i might
be aware she's involved in and also the
covered pandemic and issues like that i
would just like to echo those comments
because a tremendous amount of research
and thought has gone into this but i do
agree what we need now is the actions
and those actions must be reasonable and
achievable and we need to have a
performance that because people will as
you've said chairman strategy is one
thing you've really made got to make
that strategy come alive and then you've
got to show what your outcomes are from
it not outputs beer outcomes so thank
you very much chairman
yes thank you chairman um yeah this
strategy provides a great opportunity to
engage with a full spectrum of the
community and it will give people a
voice
within it and a reason to come together
to offer their time skills and knowledge
and to share their ideas with us
and look at the changes that are
required and also
we'll be looking to them they'll be
holding us to account for this through
that group
so we're looking for real engagement you
know we've said we want an asset based
community development approach which is
a term which really means
the assets are our residents it's the
people in this district and it's those
that we want to work with to further
inform the action plan and to work with
us to to ensure that this is delivered
thank you mr johnson uh councillor white
uh thank you chair um yeah just
following on from this um i have to say
georgina's an awful amount of um good
work and has put a lot of work into it
but the things i've raised consistently
during these working groups which
counselor channels partly picked up on
is that we need to focus on the things
we can achieve because it's such a big
piece of work we can't possibly do
everything and so that's my concern is
that we have
some some outcomes we want to achieve
that make them small and sensible not a
massive overarching report that we've
got no hope of making a dent in
um the other thing is um we've got the
funding from magnox to or to to fund a
new employee
i can't remember the figures but i'm i
think they're very little money for
actual delivery
um and i want to be mindful that we
actually deliver and don't just
have extra staff so it's another concern
i'd just like and to take into account
and and how we're going to stop this
happening and the other thing is just
say that the government um at cop26 has
um
pledged millions of pounds towards
nature and biodiversity and and in
improving the um
the airflow in in and farming practices
so hopefully that will do some good um
thank you
mrs
thank you chairman um
i think the strategy needs to be
aspirational the action plan needs to be
realistic annually about about what we
can
achieve within that
um we haven't secured the the funding
yet that the
the member refers to
um but we have got a bid in for 125 000
um over over three years um and we will
look at working with partners to look at
how once that the officer is in place
we've developed the action plan how we
can attract further funding for the the
delivery of that action plan
actions are set out under the pledges um
but they need to be refined into that
that annual plan and that's where that
realism of what can be achieved each
year will be
based but in the context of those it
needs to be aspirational
to to meet the challenges that that
we're up against with the climate yeah
yeah i i i've not been involved in the
in the working group but obviously i've
had a conversation with with uh ms
button about the strategy and i had that
same concern about you know how far are
we stretching ourselves and i'm
reassured that our approach is sensible
and reasonable and will work
um and that's my baby cancer stuff
thank you chair allowing me to come back
i've just put a couple of notes down you
start small you've got to take the
community you've got to take everybody
of all ages with you you've got to do
everyday things we've all got to start
and change and talking about the cost to
the council yes there will be a cost but
if we don't start to do it there's a
bigger cost to the world i think that
council drum actually alluded to that
anyway
um i think it's important that we do
start to make small small changes as
quickly as we can i attended um the
event in in braintree with georgina
button and there was the most fantastic
one of the young people spoke i won't
mention her name because i don't know if
i'm allowed to but hopefully she'll come
to the council in
december to do a presentation to full
council when she stood up and spoke she
was believe me she was very tall anyway
she made me look very tiny but she spoke
with such great enthusiasm and
aspirations not aspirations on what we
need to do
what we how we need to take people
forward and if we don't take them
forward she spoke far better than what
many speakers do
and you know within 30 seconds i
actually was brought into what she was
saying and i think if we have that sort
of um
person young person
you know we are going to be in safe
hands but we've also got to do our part
and i know and council jarvis is
absolutely spot on we have to balance it
with a report but we've also it will be
a cost to the council but as i said
it'll be a bigger cost to everybody else
if we don't uh and yes once again i'm
going to congratulate georgina button on
doing this piece of work but yes we do
need to crack on with it um but we've
all got to get along with it and we've
all got to do our bit so thank you for
allowing me to come back hey
and i agree with those sentiments well
hardly and and
yeah as someone like mr dodds but i
probably did it earlier than him um i
studied environmental science at the end
of the 1970s and and
i knew then that there was a concern
about our climate it wasn't a big thing
then but yeah in 1979 i was there and i
was marching and all sorts
i won't go into that um but you know
that to me i knew there was a problem in
the 1970s
but nobody really paid attention to that
particular time and now we're maybe
doing it a bit too late
cancer swings
yes i mean
the um benefit of having a specialist um
uh involved in this from um is that it
is a complex of the complexes to it and
working
through the so-called pathways to
actually achieve things
um
is going to be intricate uh there is
also this big communications issue which
is mentioned so that um
another aspect of or skill
we need in this person
um
but as far as um and we obviously need
to monitor performance of what is being
achieved but
although the costs are likely to be
quite easy to quantify in financial
terms
the actual returns and benefits from it
are going to be largely unquantified
and will have to be based on judgment of
what um what is being achieved what the
outcome is yeah thank you councilwoman
cancer durham
yeah just just really very quickly i
think we need to start um
we need to start at home and if i'm not
much mistaken this building's heated by
gas boilers is that right yeah so we
need to we need to get our house in
order literally and be looking at that
but we can look you know there
of course there will be a cost but we
need to look at investor save
first and there may be things there
because you know this is really
important you know we know even with a
one and a half uh degree
temperature increase in
by 2050
we will be looking out this window we'll
have a sea front view here
and hey bridge will be under water as
well two-thirds of the density peninsula
so you know this is real and 2050 is
only 30 years away so there is no time
to mess about but as i said let's get
our own house in order and then we can
start dictating to other people what
they should do
and we are doing that cancer dorm and
and we had a capital bid that i
questioned because it seemed a bit
strange in terms of our climate training
strange strategy
and and therefore that's concept to look
at in more detail so it is something
that we all you know as a council we
need to ensure that we're setting the
example
um and everybody i think is committed to
that cancer staff
chairman if you'd like allow me to come
back one final time i'd like to reassure
councillor durham that yes it was only
in term uh for one year but there was
lots of projects and hard work that this
council has been doing that will come to
fruition in the next few months
hopefully depending on how members
support them the officers have done a
lot of hard work behind the scenes and
talking about the building there's lots
of things i can't talk about but what i
will say is everything you're raising
and the areas of concerns you have are
being addressed and hopefully very soon
i'll look at the offices the directors
even and they will actually be bringing
papers to council so it is in hand
cancer doing but i welcome you raising
those points thank you counselor you
will be part of that working group
okay so the uh the the two
recommendations is this little one is to
the committee and little two is to
council um and that is the strategy of
approved endorse which has got to go to
full council
do we agree that by a sense
thank you very much
uh so we move now to agenda item 11 and
that's a rule settlement list found on
pages 139 to 142. um screen customers
community and caseworker manager is
going to present this mr screen
thank you chairman um
on the amount of relief that we can
grant um in respect of uh business rate
relief
for rural businesses um
can only be granted if we publish an
annual list of those settlements so the
report that's in front of you this
evening is the list which we have to
refresh annually
and the list is the same as the list was
presented last year because there
haven't been any significant changes to
either the size or the areas of the
settlements to which this scheme relates
the rural settlement relief relates to
post offices or pubs that are in a rural
settlement
where they have below 300 residents so
as you'll see from appendix say there's
a list of those particular settlements
as i said this has to be refreshed
annually and approved by members on an
annual basis so this report is just for
us members to approve that list
thank you mr scream and so the
recommendation is set out and the report
is as follows that the rules rural
settlement list attached as appendix a
be approved do i have a second of lease
councillor staff thank you
uh any comments memphis uh councillor
white so quickly um is it supposed to be
three thousand residents rather than
three hundred or am i not awake tonight
apologies remember it was three things i
did one
i thought even i don't even little
totten doesn't fit
any other questions
okay
thank you very much so uh members can we
agree that by a sense
thank you very much
so we moved to agenda item 12 which is
the marketing and communications
strategy progress update found on pages
143-164
mr dodson
thank you chairman
this report provides an update on the
marketing and communities communications
strategy
presented in appendix one which was
approved by this committee on the 17th
of october 2019.
much of the strategy has been impacted
by the co impacted by the kobit 19
pandemic
um we've seen a significant shift in
digital activity and have had to carry
out stay away campaigns instead of
coming come and visit the the district
um campaigns but um hopefully officers
um hopefully members saw the the film
that we made at the time which was don't
come now but when the time is right do
come so hopefully we promoted the
district
well it was telling people not to come
at that time
um despite the challenges we've faced
since this strategy was approved we've
successfully adapted and changed to the
needs of the service
we'll continue to update and reflect new
insights decisions opportunities and
challenges
as you'll see from the report there's
been significant activity
and i'd like to commend the work of the
team at both the quality and the volume
of output that they've provided
our communications marketing and
engagement will continue to be outcome
led and drive channel shift where
appropriate continuing to embed our
digital approach with partners and
customers thank you johnson so the
recommendations are set out the report
are as follows that little one that the
committee acknowledges the amount of
work carried out by the team to
communicate covet 19 guidance and the
impact it has had on the team's ability
to deliver any face-to-face engagement
and tourist specific activities little
two that the direction of travel of the
marketing and communication strategy be
supported acknowledging that possible
the team have developed communications
activities and this is continuously
being monitored as a pandemic guidelines
and potential winter impact involves
do i have a second
counselor doram
do we have any questions counselor
yes thank you um mr chairman um
i don't know if it's the appropriate
time to bring it up but i'm going to
bang on again this like i normally do
and that's not having anybody to man the
phones i noticed the word channel shift
and that we're all wanting to go
digitally i brought a letter of
complaint that i gladly gave to mr
holmes tonight
which was delivered to my home address
yet another resident cannot get through
to the council not everybody can get
through online
it's the same old drum chairman i say
every time and there's one thing that
i'm very disappointed i never managed to
achieve in the year i was the leader of
this council and that is to get some
funding that we have our phone lines
opened up and the channel shift well i i
agree that people want robots or bots or
whatever they're called i'm still a
great believer in that we have some
front-facing customer service and that
our phones are manned and i can feel
that i'm not being very popular with the
directors because nobody's looking at
michael
looking at me at the moment really but
i'm sorry i think we need to do it and i
appreciate it that it costs to the
council but i think the bigger cost the
council is the reputational damage i
walk around my own ward in burnham on
crouch and people are all saying to me
we can never get through wendy and we
give up and once they understand they're
going to have the numbers to back it up
people just put the phone down so i'm
sorry i really don't wish don't want to
cause havoc and cause complaints but
i'll be banging this drum until the day
i'm not in this council unless we can
get the changes i think it's vitally
important we look at that and we put
some resources in so our customers are
represented not everybody does digital
and not everybody has a mobile phone
thank you chair but the rest of it's
fine okay
who'd like to take that
mr hogan
thanks peggy chairman i heard that loud
and clear
um we are doing a lot of work on looking
at the data and seeing what the facts
are telling us unfortunately having my
customers manager sitting beside me and
sue is actually doing that piece of work
in terms of looking at the visitors um
we're looking at the previous numbers
before pandemic and who's calling us now
links of calls and that sort of thing so
there will be a review perhaps i could
ask them so just to agree to just make a
few comments
thank you members um
yeah we have done some work um on on the
data and we are currently using that
data to inform a refresh of our customer
strategy
just to give members some reassurance um
that the average time that it takes us
to deal with calls or pick calls up is
about one and a half to two minutes and
that's the data that we've got from
april so if a customer phones us it is
taking between one and a half to two
minutes to actually deal with the call
to pick that call up so i appreciate
that will vary from time to time as we
do have high demands um at times but
yeah we are dealing with something like
4 000 telephone calls a month
and as i said it's one and a half to two
minutes to answer those calls so
appreciate that isn't going to be the
same for absolutely everybody's
experience
but that hopefully will reassure members
that we are delivering a good service
yeah thank you for that but it's not
covering the actual issue that i mean um
and people put the phone down so you i'm
not saying the council is not um
answering queries and delivering it you
everybody officer and gives us a
brilliant service but my issue is that
people put the phone down i know it my
inbox and i always pass them on to you
and richard holmes since i've been the
leader before when i was the leader and
i still would like it looking at and
you can put as much data in front of me
and anybody else can but the real issue
is is what people are actually saying to
me so i'm still banging the drum
chairman until you shut me up thank you
and and we yeah i'm on that same banging
drum as you know
um and and it is about finding that
balance
which which is the difficulty yeah and
yeah the channel shift i think has
worked and has helped um but there are
still lots of people who want to speak
to someone because they don't know how
to use technology and things like that
and i can see your finger on the bottom
mr hayes
thank you so i think the customer
strategy will look at all of that and it
will give members some options of course
there's options to put staff back that's
for members to to debate and decide so
we hear what you're saying and we'll
we'll make sure that's included
mr dodson did you want to speak
um not to add anything on that on that
particular subject but but just to say
you know there's a clear difference
between our marketing and communication
strategy
and our customer service strategy yeah
thank you but they are connected they
thank you yeah i accept that
differentiation um
a week ago i was hitting this building
for my code booster jab
and because i wanted to come upstairs i
just happened to have my landlord
lanyard on and the lady said
said oh are you something to do with
here and i said yes she said i suggest
you take it off
because you'll be extremely unpopular
she said you would not believe the
number of people that come in and rant
and actually rant at the nh or the the
peop the staff the volunteers there
moaning the fact that they can't get
there's nobody here to see them and that
they can't get any response
now in a previous incarnation
i thought i would bring a business into
the 21st century and introduced
a very expensive telephone system that
allowed you know press one for this and
press two for the other
um
and it ended up costing tens of
thousands of pounds in lost business
literally tens of thousands of pounds
because people wanting to book events
couldn't be bothered going through the
whole thing and i'm afraid there is
absolutely no substitute for a human
being
answering the phone and lots of people
do not like to be answered by a machine
irrespective of those that don't have
the devices where they can
you know press three etc etc i'm afraid
i learned the lesson the hard way
and had to backtrack and it ended up
costing thousands of pounds but the good
news is when you restore the public
the person at the end
hey presto the business starts coming
back
fact
thank you chairman i'm i'm sure
screen will be looking at that in terms
of her analysis and report and we'll
come back to the
the committee with that data and that
information and and hopefully we will be
able to make a decision look at the
resources councillor wait uh thank you
chad um yeah mine really is uh just to
echo the same thing everybody says oh
you can't get hold of maldon even if you
do they never come back to you um and
that doesn't matter if it's enforcement
or or what it is so i spend my time
smoothing over why the officers are busy
um so it does need addressing and then
also as a member we can't actually get
hold of anybody and i don't know how
many times i've emailed over this ipad
because it doesn't work very well and i
have yet to get a response so i give up
you know i absolutely nobody's going to
do anything with it so you know it isn't
just
members of the public it is also members
and there's a i was actually going to
ask at full council a question over
officers responding to members queries
um and the second question i have is my
husband works for an investment house
he works from home he actually works
longer hours at home than he does at
work normally he leaves court suit to
seven in the morning and gets home close
to eight at night when he's because he
works on the west end london
um actually he's working longer hours on
the three days he works from home now
he's in work two days a week but the
point i'm getting to is one is are we
monitoring the work was actually being
done because i don't know how their
computer systems do it they know when
they're active and not just clicking a
mouse once an hour
and the second thing is i don't
understand why we can't get hold of
members they have their normal work
headsets i don't know how it works they
take phone calls through those headsets
exactly the same as they do at work and
it's part of their contract they have to
be available on the phone so
and if then they have to have also a
mobile phone backup
and he said it's exactly the same as
working in the office so
why does our council not manage to work
like investment houses are working i
don't understand
why we cannot contact officers well in
terms of the telephone system i think it
does work in that way and there's an
electronic system that will go to
whoever is free at that particular time
so it does work in that way and they are
at home on their headsets or or they're
in the office in terms of my own
experience in in getting contact and
getting responses from the officers i
think it's brilliant i i yeah i use
fresh service i put things in there you
know sometimes i email sometimes i use
fresh service and usually i get a
response
within a day um so yeah
i i my own personal experience of
getting responses from officers is
fantastic personally
the last one i would say check into is
the waste query that i've wasted rather
an awful lot of times and that's that's
just the
one of them and my my it is another one
there too that i can give you straight
away and you just give up you're like oh
well never mind would you want a laptop
council away no i just like one that
actually works it gets stuck it you you
type and it takes 10 minutes to catch up
with your fingers it's really
frustrating i don't know what no matter
what it is but um and i even said i
think there was a thing came around to
members they were having an upgrade of
um equipment do you want one and i said
yes please but nothing somewhere oh my
god mr holly can get in touch with you
yeah so
mr leslie can sort that out for you
yeah i must admit my experience is is
really good in terms of response from
from sue's team from richard team from
from chris's team and yeah because
that's where my a lot of my queries go
to and it's always been really really
good and it's fantastic to get that
support i know i make lots of my
residents happy as a result of that
okay
any other question missed anybody at all
okay uh so
uh can we agree that virus
okay thank you very much
uh
so we now move on to item 13 which is
any items business that the chairman of
the committee decides that our urgent
and there are none
and then we move on to item 14 um
exclusion of the public and press
to resolve that under section 10 sorry
108 brackets 4 of the local government
act 1972 the public be excluded from the
meeting for the following items of
business on the grounds that they
involve the light disclosure of exempt
information as defined in paragraph
three of part one of schedule 12a to the
act and that's this satisfies the
public's interest test can i have a
second to please cancel this way thank
you
so we just gotta wait for
the live stream to go off
you